this program is being presented to you
by the Harris International winter
school on gravity and lights so good
morning and welcome back to the ve
International winter school on gravity
and light the topic of today's tutorial
is diagrams and as most of the times we
want to start with today very short
statements but nevertheless five
statements on the Schwarzschild black
hole in Schwarzschild coordinates now
geodesics starting at our larger than 2m
never reach or smaller than to him
that's correct because when you remember
the space-time diagram where we draw the
radial in the time coordinate here and
we had the singularity at 2m and this
point is excluded so starting out of
here can never end somewhere here the
exact form of the nahji desig is like
that and like that
these are the in going ones and here
this is the part for the region are
smaller than 2m so here we can't jump
over next one a Schwarzschild black hole
is a non rotating but charged black hole
that's not correct since that's the
resna nordstrom solution and if we cross
out charged then this would be correct
but as it is phrased here it is not in
Eddington finkelstein coordinates radial
nine Jude Essex fall into the black hole
on straight lines at angle 45 degrees
that's right if you remember the diagram
that was constructed in the lecture so
here we had our again at the time he was
again two M
then these here became dead ones so
that's right
Eddington Finkelstein coordinates cover
all possible radii are in zero to
infinity as you can see that's right as
well
Nigel Essex in Schwarzschild coordinates
starting from our smaller than two M can
never leave this region that's true
again same argument as above the point
to M is excluded therefore you can't
pass this point and that's it we
continue with exercise two now geodesics
conformal transformations of the metric
have no effect on the Judaic equation
the question here is that we should show
that a curve gamma that is a naja desig
with respect to a metric gene even only
if it is an eidetic with respect to
Omega squared times G where Omega
squared is a smooth function on M there
is no where vanishing okay so what we
need to check is if we for example start
here what does that mean we have a
connection with respect to the metric G
and X is now the tangent vector to the
curve gamma then gamma is a large
geodesic
and what we want to check here is
whether if you use this condition this
one Omega squared G the other connection
X X it's again another desig that's
what's to show here and just to comment
on that that would be only the one
direction but the other follows
immediately because you just need to
invert this factor here and then that's
the same so we will just do the one
direction here okay and what we want to
look at is the eighth component of this
thing and as you know this is X a D by
DX a sorry this should be some B
otherwise we get an index conflict and
this act on X a so that's the first term
of the covariant derivative and now we
get the gammas but you need to be
careful these are the gammas with
respect to the new metric the conformal
transformed metric as we say then the a
goes here we derived with respect to B
and we maybe put some n here so we have
X B X and that should be correct okay we
continue by just leaving this term here
and we have to write out the gammas in
order to see what happens here so the
definition was one half now we get the
inverse metric in front but in order for
this to be the inverse we need the
factor 1 over Omega squared then here's
symmetric and we choose indices a D for
example I can we leave out the minus one
that should be here but
you know what that means and then inside
of here we have the metric which is
Nablus squared G Omega squared G then we
have the indices and D comma B plus
Omega squared G and now we have D B
comma n that's the next one minus Omega
squared G and here we have and B comma
and here it is d so we check it NB down
here the 1 is replaced by the summation
here and we derive with our symbol so
this comma again means D by DX B D by DX
and D by DX D okay that should be
correct and now we have a close look at
this term so here here and here we will
get some product rule that means we have
six terms in total three of them will
just reproduce the old gammas because
this Omega squared factor stays
untouched in front of each of them and
cancels with this one over Omega squared
so what we can write is d by d XB x a
plus 1/2 you know I wanted to do this
faster so we saw that this produces the
old cameras therefore this is G G gamma
up we have an A and down and be on XP X
L and I realized that here x p xn was
missile otherwise we would have some
index problems
so these are the old gammas and now we
have to carefully look at the other part
so what do we have here we have 1/2 in
front 1 over Omega squared then the
inverse metric the stays untouched and
now the bracket opens and now this
derivative acts on the Omega that means
the G stays untouched like that and now
we get to omega x omega comma b and the
same for the other terms that means g DB
twice omega x omega comma n continue
here - the g and b now times 2 omega x
omega comma d and don't forget the xpx m
so that's it up to here and now we again
analyze what we have here this one is
just knobloch eggs connection with
respect to the metric g x and of that
the 8th component but we know that this
is zero because that was our starting
point so this one is gone so in the
right part we may have a closer look at
the last term here this is basically g
and b XP xn but g and b XP xn is just a
length of the curve and since we started
from knowledge of ethics this one is
gone as well so what remains we do some
reordering this 2 cancels this 2 here 1
of the square the square goes
and what remains is one over Omega G ad
and there it is G and now we see that
because of the sum here and the symmetry
of the metric we can write this also as
two times G and D Omega comma B now we
have xB X and that should be correct
okay so what's the next step you can
pull the two ouch
that means we stay with this one and now
one where we could contract these two
here that means we sum over the D and
get some Kronecker Delta a n okay and
this a n takes this one and makes this
one into an a it means we have comma B
that one stays untouched these produce
to Delta and this one gets some XA okay
that looks quite nice one further step
may be so we can also write this as
twice the X acting on the logarithm of
Omega and
this whole thing times X a because the X
acts as a derivative that means 1 over
Omega is here the 2 is there already and
then we need to derive the inner part
and this is just Omega comma B if we
expand the X in some sum over the B's ok
and now we carefully look at this term
and maybe call it alpha so what's left
is alpha times X a and if you look at
this one that's just a function because
that's a function a vector field acting
on a function produces a function this
is in total just a function on M that
means we can think of that as some
parameter that scales the value and if
you remember the most general form of
the geodesic equation that was this one
and only if we do some affine
parameterization this one goes but it
has not to go in order to for X to be
the tension to some do desig and since
we started up here with the left part of
the geodesic equation and arrived at the
right part of the Judaic equation this
is correct and we showed that if we
start from an algae disick for this
connection then this conformal
transformation doesn't change that
it changes the parameterization but that
doesn't matter because it's nevertheless
a geodesic and that's it
okay so in the third exercise we want to
carefully construct the Penrose diagram
of a radiation field universe so we will
guide you through all the necessary
steps in order to produce the Penrose
diagram for this situation and the first
step here is that we find the exact form
of the radial null geodesics here so
first we read the question find a
differential equation for radial
knowledge of ethics so that it's
important in a spatially flat frw
universe filled with radiation we should
use this charge and then write
explicitly down the range of the chart
variables okay so the first thing that
we notice is we are spatially flat that
means Kappa equals zero our universe is
filled with radiation and if you
remember the scale factor was
proportional to t to the two over n for
all values of Omega that appears here so
this one basically comes from the
equation of stage that is P equals Rho
times Omega and different omegas produce
different metro types or radiation here
and for radiation we had Omega equals 1
over 3 if we plug that in here that
means 3 times 4/3 produces a 4 and that
means in our case we have T to the
one-half as our scale factor
okay we only want to consider radio now
geodesics and that implies that theta
dot and Phi dot equals zero in our case
and a very easy way to find the this
differential equation for the night
geodesics as a following so we know that
the Lagrangian in a suitable
parameterization is zero or it is it is
always zero because it allows you that
six that means the length is zero and we
can explicitly write out the Lagrangian
so this would be minus t dot squared
plus t times r dot squared and that's it
because the metric for the flat case was
just - in the zero zero component and
some a squared in the spatial part and a
squared is just T so this is our
Lagrangian and we can do some reordering
here to start a little earlier that
means we put this to the other side and
divide by our dot squared that means we
have T dot over our dot the whole thing
squared and this is equal to T now we
take the square root that means we have
T dot over r dot equals plus minus
square root of G and now we look at this
expression that is DT over D lambda for
example if we call the parameter so and
now in the denominator r dot but this is
just the lambda over D R and this after
application of the chain rule is DT by D
R so we have this differential part of
this equation and and since this is
precisely what we want because we want
to draw a diagram
t R so we need T in dependence on R that
means this is the same as now I will
write the integrals at first so this is
1 over square root of T we divide by
that here it is T T equals integral plus
minus dr okay this can be solved you get
one integration constant because we
integrate once and on the left hand side
we get twice square root of T and on the
right hand side we get C plus minus R C
is a constant now we can divide by 2 and
square the whole expression and we get T
of R equals 1 over 4 C plus minus R
squared so that's oh I see that we
already solved what should be solved in
the next question but actually it
doesn't matter so we maybe put that here
so we should determine the T coordinate
of this geodesic in terms of its R
coordinate and that's what we did
already but what we forget was the range
of these two variables so the T is in
and our vision okay T should be greater
than 0 and R as well so this is our
range here we will for each of the steps
explicitly write down the ranges of the
coordinates because that's particularly
important for constructing these
diagrams okay and I will put the form of
the geodesics again here so that's this
one and now we can draw a diagram in
which we put some of the geodesics and
by some women we take the plus
take the - and we shift by the sea so
this essentially looks like that
so we have the are here T is normally on
the y-axis and now we need to draw many
parabola um so for example this one that
one
of course they start over here so we get
this one as well and I get this one and
like that it continues but one thing
that is important since we specified
these ranges here this one and this one
and this one and this one they are not
part of the diagram so T is larger than
zero that means here these are really
two different geodesics so this is the
first and that's the second one in that
chart that's how it looks
okay now we are asked to find some
transformation that is another charge
and where these curves here are lines of
constant slope plus minus 1 and that's
always the second step so we need to
make the null geodesics that run on
arbitrary curves to some curves that are
like that or like that and we will see
how this works
and I wanna rescale the T that means we
have some new T that of course may
depend on T R theta and Phi and one way
to find this one is to first solve this
equation for R so we do that that would
be R equals plus minus twice the square
root of t minus C see if this is correct
so times three times four and then we
take the square root and get 2 times the
square root and then plus minus because
of that one and minus C should be
correct and since we want all lines to
be straight lines of constant slope plus
minus one then it would be good to
define this one as a new t bar so T bar
is now defined as twice square root of
the old team okay you could basically
rescale the R coordinate as well but
that essentially doesn't matter okay
again we draw some diagram so it's not
asked here but it helps to understand
what happens here so now we have the are
here and the T bar here and now we get
lines of constant slope plus one and
straight lines of constant slope minus
one and of course the C shifts them here
and we again look at the ranges of
course the are stayed the same and the
TT bar also stayed the same since we
just took the square root okay so that's
basically it for the first three
questions here and one remark I have to
make is that why we exclude T equals
zero that's important because this is
our singularity the Big Bang so to say
and you can see that here actually
because we choose some particular dust
model or some now we choose some
radiation model this one with Omega
equals 1 over 3 and if you look at the
metric this produces minus 1 T and then
it continues and the T here if this gets
zero then the metric would be degenerate
and this is what we usually call a
singularity so that's not good and
therefore we need to exclude the T
equals 0 and that results in these
points that are excluded yep and the
last thing we could do is this our D and
these are the set the ingoing ones and
these are the outgoing ones I hope
that's correct yes so outgoing in going
okay so that's it and we continue with
the next question because we're not done
yet okay
let's continue with the next question
which is about the so called null
coordinates that we normally call U and
V and the idea here was so the result
from the last step was R and T bar and
we had the geodesics as curves of
constant slope plus minus 1 the idea
here is now to cleverly rotate the
coordinate system such that this is the
U axis and this is the V axis that means
the knowledge of the six run parallel to
the both axis and we just define you as
T bar plus R and V as T bar minus R ok
so if we do that we arrived precisely at
this situation and we first look at the
range so T plus R these are both
positive as we checked in the exercise
before or in the question before
services in 0 to infinity and V is in
minus infinity to infinity now we have
to draw the diagram and that means I
want you on this axis so here is U that
is V and we can exclude this area maybe
I have to somehow like that otherwise
you can tell that means so V is U is
larger than 0 and we know that geodesics
now look like that so that's
first direction and these are the others
but now we can further constrain this
thing because we can for example look at
you plus B which is twice T bar which is
of course greater than zero and what
that means is that we can also exclude
this part here because here for example
this point we have u equals Q for
example and V equals minus three or four
and then this would be negative so this
is excluded and similarly we can look at
U minus V which is twice R which is
again greater than zero and this
condition will exclude that part so we
are left with this kind of wedge here
where you may run to infinity but now we
have all the knowledge of ethics along
the coordinate axis and the reason to do
this is because now we want to
compactify this that means we take some
function that produces out of the
Infinity some finite value and by doing
that this function that produces this
cannot be linear therefore the Cohen
structure would not be preserved if it
would be like that because then for
example a cone that first looks like
that by this transformation could after
that maybe look like that which we don't
want therefore we put the knowledge of
ethics on the coordinate axis and then
the rescaling just produces something
like that okay so we will do that and
one suitable function is the arc tangent
so here we have PI half minus PI half
like that and now this is and that's
also important a strictly monotonous
curve so we define you know capital EU
that is the arc tangent of the small U
and similarly for the V and since this
one is strictly monotonous all the
conditions that we had before
now also hold for the capital u and
small V and capital V so maybe first
ranges so this you can check up here was
the small u was from zero to infinity
that means the capital u is from zero to
pi half and for the V we had minus
infinity that could be a possible value
so this is the range but as I said the
conditions that u plus V must be greater
than zero and you - we must be greater
than zero
also hold so we can draw a diagram it
looks like this we have you again here
and B here so this would be something
like that where here we have I have here
we have I have here we are at minus PI
half and all the other stuff is now not
part of our diagram and still the
geodesics are either that or that so we
preserve the cone structure with which
is this one but compactified or one
would better say bounded our range of
coordinates so that was the second last
step and the file transformation that we
have to do is
again recover some or a notion of
temporal and radial coordinates because
the whole idea of this Penrose Penrose
Carter diagram is to make some
statements on the causal structure and
therefore we must preserve temporal and
radial coordinates in the way that we
are used to them so we want to have some
are here and some T here so that's the
the aim and then we can talk about
future and past okay and the final
transformation basically undo this up
here but of course with the bounded new
coordinate capital u and capital V so we
define R and T where T is now u plus me
and this is now u minus V okay
what we immediately see because of these
conditions is that they both are larger
than zero which is good because we want
this to be some radio and some and some
temporal coordinate so we can write T
starts at zero and our also starts in
zero and in principle they can go up to
PI both of them can check the U is at
maximum PI half the V as well so this
one is clear and for the R coordinate
it's the same because we subtract minus
PI half that's adding PI half and we
have this range here that is in
principle possible so we draw the
diagram that now is just this one so we
have the are here and the T there and
maybe put the PI so that's it
and we basically could have
everything that's in here but of course
there are more conditions that is for
example if you look at T plus R what is
that this is twice you just using the
definition here and we have seen that U
is sorry wrong way around we saw that U
is smaller than PI half therefore twice
U is smaller than PI what that means is
adding these both up must be smaller
than pi
this means we arrive here where this is
excluded so this is out and since we
kind of rotated back the knowledge of
ethics again look like that or like that
and here at T equals zero we have the
singularity our Big Bang okay so that
was basically constructing the Carter
Penrose diagram for a radiation field
frw universe that is spatially flat